what does mrs potts an enchantress's
curse
and a corset all have in common they're
just some of the key differences between
the 1991
animated original beauty and the beast
and its 2017
live action remake but did these changes
hit the mark or completely wilt the rose
of this beloved disney classic
today we're going to compare side by
side some of the differences and
pinpoint our favorite creative choices
and even some beastly flops made in the
2017
remake are you making jokes now
maybe there's no question that of the
disney princesses
belle is definitely one of the more
feminist characters
not only is she a princess with tons of
agency but she also isn't afraid to
stand her ground against the stubborn
and unrefined beast
so when emma watson got the role in 2017
live action flick
it was important for her to work
alongside the director and writers to
make the disney princess a role model
for modern audiences everywhere
according to sources one of her
decisions was that belle should
not wear a corset in the disney remake
despite the historic significance of the
garment
this was especially important
considering that the cinderella
live-action remake was heavily
criticized for exactly this reason
just check out this side-by-side
comparison of the animated disney
princess
and her live-action counterpart it's
obvious in the original
disney animators cinched belle's waist
but emma watson's interpretation of the
character is
far more realistic pretty eyes
proud face perfect canvas
yes another uploaded twist to the live
action film
is belle's backstory and hobby as an
inventor we all know that in the
animated film
maurice bell's father is a wacky
inventor
with tons of gizmos and gadgets fans
speculate that since belle is so close
to her father
she must have picked up on a thing or
two from him which is why she feels so
comfortable
handing him a missing tool in the disney
live action remake the storyline is
taken up a notch with belle
as the intellectual inventor while her
father is an artist
who builds music boxes and become a
world
famous inventor you really believe that
i always have in this animated film
other than the opening song it's not
really disclosed why belle is an
outsider in her small french village
other than she's an odd girl who reads
teaching another girl to read isn't one
enough
but in the live-action film it's much
more pronounced why belle is an outsider
not only is she a girl who always has
her nose deep in a book
but she also is a skilled inventor which
was an extremely unusual hobby for a
woman at this time
what's he doing the laundry
plus there's also the fact that belle a
beautiful woman doesn't want to marry
gaston
the allegedly most handsome man in the
village sure these modern audiences may
frown at these close-minded attitudes
but it's important to remember that
these were common attitudes of 18th
century france in which the story takes
place
gaston may i have my book please how can
you read this
there's no pictures in the animated film
it's immediately explained how and why
the prince was cursed into the beast
but in the live-action remake audiences
get a deeper insight into the prince's
backstory including the fact that he was
not only someone who judged people
based on their appearances but was also
extremely selfish and unkind
she offered the prince a single rose
[Laughter]
fans who paid attention may have also
picked up that like bell
the beast's mother also died when he was
very young and that his dad was
extremely wicked which may explain why
the beast turned out the way he did
you can't judge people by who their
father is now can
you a true mark of belle's heroism
and selflessness it's her willingness to
take her father's place
in the beast's prison but in the
live-action remake she's slightly more
sneaky on how she goes about it are you
so cold-hearted you won't allow a
daughter to kiss her father goodbye
in the animated movie belle takes her
father's place by negotiating with the
beast that she will take his place
of course maurice isn't happy about this
choice at
all but the beast accepts her offer and
forcefully drags the unwilling father
out
but in the live-action version bella's a
bit more sneaky
in the scene when they're reunited belle
gives her father a big embrace
before locking herself in the beast's
prison at the last minute you took his
place
he's my father of course the catalyst
moment that sparks the beasts and bells
meeting
is the imprisonment of her father in the
original maurice gets lost
riding through the forest and ultimately
gets imprisoned for
trespassing into the castle in an effort
to seek refuge
but then in the live action maurice
enters and exits the castle freely when
he discovers the castle
but gets caught red-handed trying to
steal a single white rose for his
daughter
which is a tradition between maurice and
belle this is not only a storyline
that's more true to the original beauty
and the beast story but it also offers a
bit more context
to why maurice was imprisoned in the
first place after all trespassing is one
thing but theft is another
i just needed a place to stay i'll give
you a place to stay
it's always an open-ended and
non-discussed mystery
why the village did not know about the
beast's castle before belle and her
father discover the mysterious palace in
the animated film
but with more on-screen time to
elaborate upon storylines
the audience finds out that for once and
for all that the enchantress cast
a spell not only on the prince and his
castle but also
the village people practically overnight
not only was the memory of the entire
village wiped but those with loved ones
who worked in the castle
seem to have forgotten their loved ones
this makes the ending of the
action film that much more heartwarming
as tons of characters are reunited with
their loved ones
taking an animated classic from the 90s
to the 21st century is
already not an easy task but the
director bill condon was adamant
about diversifying the cast and
storyline of beauty and the beast
in an interview condon disclosed even
before the film had premiered on the big
screen
that there would be a nice exclusively
gay moment
in which lefou gaston sidekick would
navigate his burgeoning sexuality on
screen
despite controversy disney stuck to its
guns and decided once and for all to
keep the seamlessly harmless
scenes in their 2017 updated classic
too much yep lumiere solo is without a
doubt
one of the most iconic songs in the
entire film
and with good reason it's visually
stunning both in the original
and live action film but the 1991
version was much easier to film and
produce
than the 2017 remake by a long shot
other than emma the entire musical
sequence were special effects
yep you heard us right according to the
director the musical number took
approximately
two and a half years to plan shoot and
edit
in post in order to bring this song to
life
your dinner
[Music]
we've already gotten warm motherly vibes
from mrs potts in the animated film
but when it was time to bring her
character to life in the live-action
film
some slight alterations had to be made
unlike her animated counterpart
the new and improved mrs potts does not
have a poor stout
or nose why because she would have
looked too much like a big
otherwise mama am i ever going to be a
boy again
oh yes chip so do you think the live
action remake withstood the test of time
are you still a die hard fan of the 1991
original
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for all of your side-by-side video
comparisons
[Music]